hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Black Rose now this is a
highly reviewed indie horror game that
is not exactly new but I'm very eager to
give it a try because people say that it
is exceptionally scary in their reports
of the ghosty girl in this game is
rather ghastly and gargantuan but in a
good way I guess um I don't know
anything else about the game honestly it
came out about a year ago I think on
different channels but it wasn't very um
I don't want to say it wasn't popular I
just want to say that it was very
distributed ok so far I found two dead
ends and two windows that lead to
nowhere whatever you got for me game I'm
ready to get the pants scared off of me
oddly enough I am wearing pants today I
don't know why I need to give you guys a
pants update every time I start
recording a game that's probably pretty
weird at this point but either way this
is someone else here I scribbled on this
note for no apparent reason
why am I here I seem to be in an
abandoned building maybe I'm scouting
out a new location for my nightmare
factory but other than that why would I
be here why the eternal question burning
in everyone's mind when they play these
war games why why do I need to be here
why is there nothing under the stairs
and why is there a girl laughing in the
distance oh well let's see oh is this
another door that I could've gone to in
the beginning okay
I'll live back around and try to find
something else hey lady laughing hey
chuckles you want to come over here and
laughed in my face got something for you
it's called a fists knuckle sandwich
thing boss says not to go near myrtles
coffin Myrtle why won't the grave digger
bury it anyway it's not like the what
boss says is true I mean the dead can't
really talk
can they is this a note of the idiot
before who asked all those questions
you're not supposed to ask in horror
movies you know the ones like what could
possibly go wrong
I couldn't get murdered while I'm taking
a shower it's dim but I might be able to
force it open I would need to ram it a
couple times
this seems like a bad idea oh yeah
that's a good let's do that again huh
yeah I expected it to not take that many
times there's a baby monitor here
strange why did I take the baby monitor
why do I care about what demon babies
crying in the night this house is very
obviously haunted and I do not like what
was the point of ramming that just for
the baby monitor who's that from the
baby monitor is that just ambience okay
all right now game you're starting to
get into it I feel it I feel the
atmosphere
no thank you I would much rather not you
are not a baby who was that I thank you
I don't want to come downstairs why
would I do that that seems like it's
utter death coming down those which
stairs which stairs who the death stairs
okay well I am a brave man guessing
these stairs cuz they progressed forward
no okay
not those stairs you meant the other
stairs demon laughing lady hey hey hey
what you want
well okay oh you meant all the way
downstairs let me just double-check that
you didn't mean over here oh okay okay
so the demon baby lady is downstairs
chuckles big laugh a lot is down here no
one want to tell me why I'm walking into
the basement willingly at the advice of
some crazy demonic lady no really hope
that I don't I really hope I'm not
walking into instant death here I don't
know if it's gonna start me out at the
beginning I don't think there was a save
mechanic on this bad boy do not like you
I do not like anything that is happening
right now all dead end good by me I'm
getting flashbacks to vanish you know I
still get comments everywhere I go about
you haven't finished vanish you haven't
beaten was that it's not actually I
think
I get comments saying that I haven't
beaten vanish everywhere I go
that's nice I promise I will beat it
someday I will officially be do I know I
got close I got the key and I got to the
door and I wish that I could say that
that was me beating this stupid game
why am I here there's nothing down here
I went everywhere what was the point try
to be something else down there right
there had to be something else what am i
doing but either way I promise you guys
I will beat it no matter what that game
I'm going to literally just sit down and
finish the game and holy crap what is
going on here am i all god this this Hey
he higher eyes don't look in her eyes
whose eyes Chuck oh god myrtles coffin
why man mertle's coffin Oh Crypt Keeper
the other baby monitor is down here it's
word not sure I want to be here anymore
something feel
oh now something feels wrong okay I'm
out here goodbye everybody I'm gonna go
home now go away really quickly
after Lula dot what happened what's
going on what is going on why is this
happening to me
doors locked Oh God
it wasn't earlier it was bad no thank
you I can't move Jesus was an ass [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ]
get away from me lady I really would
rather not play with you at the moment
door was locked it wasn't earlier Grammy
going now
oh no I better get trapped okay I think
I gotta go I think I gotta go look she's
following me okay I'm just gonna assume
that that was all scripted and I'm not
gonna die yet yet yet
I plan on dying very soon I guess oh I
really hope that if I die Don come back
to the beginning please open there's a
checkpoint system maybe this way I guess
this would progress deeper into the
building huh
no goes it all doesn't have your oh god
I'm so dead
well I was right about one thing I was
dead Jesus I tried to call it the door
and then I just stared at her oh god
it's gonna turn me back to the beginning
isn't it please oh my dads are gonna be
so disappointed at me shut up chuckles
she's so happy why is she so happy
she's so smiley so if I can't manage to
close this door I really hope that I can
oh god good don't go there
oh god what do i do what do i do no no
no aah
just good oh god she's gonna kill me
where is she
am i alive hello where's this go close
it
oh god it's lousy what-do-i-do
what-do-i-do what-do-i-do what-do-i-do
oh god I can't see laughs girl I got
away from me it's good Jews right there
huh I got a score point zoom in on that
score Barry 75 point units Jesus Christ
I have an overloaded the mic like that
in a while
oh god I did not like that
I did not like that sam-i-am I do not
like green hams at green eggs and you
whatever god I screw that up that's
locked what is the point of coming down
there what do I gotta do now
gonna win that's what I got to do but I
don't know how I guess I gotta find a
key she's just gonna appear randomly as
out of this game is gonna work how big
of a douche you're gonna be to me that's
not open a bull the door's locked I bet
this one's also locked whoa where do I
go what do I do
can i Ram the chest down there because I
have a feeling I need something out of
that I've already gone here God
everything is locked I think I might
have supposed to pan to die maybe I
broke game maybe I broke it broke
everything
I gotta go back downstairs and pride
good idea go back to test shows and back
to her coffin cuz surely a dress she
wouldn't be oh good is open I got a key
we good for me Oh kill me don't yell out
my god
what hell oh god Anna no no no no no no
no no no no no what I'll do no no no
Shannon Myrtle
Shannon Myrtle Myrtle Myrtle Manon man
and Myrtle you go away you go away
oh god if do not like you I like you
okay good I'm stopped safe I think open
it do it didn't do it here
where is he okay I'm good I'm good open
it yeah yeah yeah the only way to keep
Myrtle in her coffin for good is to lock
it I thought I unlocked it before but
someone else must have unlocked it in
that or the lid was forced to open this
key here it's labeled Myrtle so I got a
way I gotta go Locker coffin I gotta go
back down there you son of a [ __ ] I was
just there why was the key to open that
in their coffin seems kind of
counterintuitive okay here we go again
third time's the charm goddamn my heart
is beating a million miles an hour like
it like it like it like it she in there
it's probably do with the no scent I
need like to sing
what what does that mean
that's a Slendy tubby scream maybe oh
god oh god
gran
God ever read Jesus
very romantic
go in
baby about a two thousand ninety three
thousand about eighty nine thousand
ninety nine whoa kids oh my god I did it
huh that seemed a lot longer than just
five minutes and 53 seconds okay I can
stop screaming now cheese God sorry
neighbors it's early in the morning it's
too much for this god I don't know what
it was about that game but I was like in
a panic the entire time
God knows awesome you guys got to play
that for yourselves I bet I miss Olivia
there was some doors that he didn't open
oh my goodness
I love that who's great I was wondering
why it was very highly reviewed it just
seemed like on the surface another unity
horror game got my voice already i
thrashed it hang out give me a give me a
give me a second to calm down into my
normal voice here but either way that
was awesome I really enjoyed that that
was very very well made um I didn't see
the developer website of this game I was
trying to find it but I had to play this
on other site so there'll be a link for
you to play it in the description below
definitely give it a check because this
game is very nice and I would like to
see more games from this developer
because it's very simple but it was very
good and very panic-inducing because i
had no idea what was going on with that
lady chasing me so either way thank you
all so much for watching thank you all
for playing this or whatever
thank you all so much for watching check
out the other [ __ ] games that I played
in the description below and then the
annotations it's a huge playlist like a
hundred and fifty games so check it out
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye hello
everybody my name is markiplier welcome
a little bit a little bit a little bit
but I do think I have ever read
baba Dimity Manila gonna grab
now okay yum-yum-yum-yum yum-yum-yum
Dabba Dabba there
a little bit better
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba ba-ba-ba black rose black
rose black rose black rose black rose
black roars black cause black crows
black rose black rose ah hello ah but
what's the thing hold you nothing